[Music]
we're going to the moon and we're just
getting started
after 100 days of deep space Cruise the
series one Lander arrived in lunar orbit
successful completion of this long
voyage that only validates the series
one lunar lander design it represents
the completion of a series of successes
for ispace the verification of our
communication technology structural
design software maneuver operations and
others all while having overcome
unexpected issues and hurdles along the
way
after completing a series of orbital
control maneuvers
the Lander is scheduled to initiate its
automated Landing sequence from lunar
orbit
throughout this phase the Lander
continues to orbit the Moon while
approaching its designated landing area
other than the primary Landing location
in Atlas crater three alternative sites
can be targeted in case that any
anomalies or other unexpected events
prevent the start of the landing
sequence for the primary candidate site
in that case additional orbits are
performed to align the Landers
trajectory with the new Target sites and
to allow for optimal use of lunar
daytime after landing
during the landing sequence the Lander
performs a series of automated actions
approximately one hour before planned
touchdown the Lander begins to deorbit
insertion phase firing its Thruster to
reduce its parallel altitude from
approximately 100 kilometers to 25
kilometers
continuing on its orbit the Lander moves
to The Far Side of the Moon losing
direct line of sight and communication
with ground station
approximately 45 minutes later the
Lander reappears from behind the moon
and begins its braking burn to slow down
its descent onboard instruments are used
to determine the distance from the lunar
surface the Lander utilizes a power
descend control algorithm developed by
Draper Laboratories using proprietary
guidance navigation and Control software
drawing from years of experience dating
back to the Apollo program
in the final moments before landing the
Lander relies on its assist thrusters to
perform a soft touchdown
[Music]
attempting a lunar Landing brings many
challenges this truly a daring Endeavor
the impact of Landing is mitigated by a
shock absorption system inside the
landing gear after landing the lantern
performs initial checkout activities to
confirm the Integrity of its systems
simultaneously stable power delivery to
all systems is resumed and electricity
is generated via the surface mounted
solar arrays a high gain antenna will be
used when attempting to establish
Communications with ground station
next the deployment and operation of
payloads begins such as the uae's
Rasheed Rover as part of the Emirates
lunar Mission a transformable lunar
robot for the Japan Aerospace
Exploration Agency
experimental devices such as solid-state
batteries by newtera and multiple
payloads within the Canadian space
agency's LEAP program
on mission 1 surface operations are
expected to last approximately 10 days
effectively using lunar daytime for the
Lander and its payloads to perform
various tasks among others and
representing the first such transaction
of its kind
ownership of lunar regolith is planned
to be captured by the ispace series 1
Lander during landing and will be
transferred to NASA as part of the
Artemis program
as the first mission of the series one
Lander data collected during the entire
Mission duration will contribute towards
future developments
and will help to improve the performance
and reliability of ispaces Hardware
during its next missions
mission 2 is currently planned for 2024
and testing has already begun with
several customers already standing by to
have their payloads transported to the
Moon
planned for 2025 Mission 3 will be
utilized for the Fulfillment of NASA
Clips task orders as a member of Team
Draper preparations are underway and are
progressing rapidly
we're aiming to perform the world's
first lunar Landing by a commercial
Enterprise
this is the beginning of our vision to
create a CIS lunar economy ispace is in
it for the long ride and we're just
getting started never quit the lunar
Quest
[Music]
hello everyone this is shiroshi yamakawa
president of the Japan Aerospace
Exploration Agency Jackson
I'm sure you are all very excited to be
watching the moon landing by icepaces in
one mission
currently the United States Japan and
many other countries are planning lunar
exploration missions
these missions will be conducted through
International cooperation and in
collaboration with many Industries
while many players are aiming for the
moon the M1 Mission will be the first
commercial attempt by a private company
to land on the Moon
I'm very happy and proud that the
Japanese company is about to achieve
this challenge
also carries a transformable Runner
robot the result of joint research
between Jacksonville and private
companies
the data acquired acquired by the robot
will be used for research and
development of a crude pressurized Rover
and will contribute to Japan's future
space exploration activities
Jacksonville steadily carry out the
mission of the transformable learner
robot and pass the torch to Future than
exploration missions
lastly I wish the ml Mission a
successful landing on the moon
[Music]
dear colleagues and friends as director
General officer it is my special
pleasure to convey my best regards to
the landing event to the hakuto r lunar
lander mission 1 of i-space under
commercial contract with ispace Europe
Isa was and is responsible for ensuring
communication between the spacecraft and
its teams on Earth through the mission
the agency's global network of tracking
stations is used to transmit commands to
the spacecraft and receive scientific
data and Status information from mission
1 and the experiments carried out on the
moon the mission underpins the
successful cooperation between Esa and
ispace
such collaboration schemes between new
space companies and space agencies open
up exciting opportunities for the future
of lunar exploration and other domains
accounting for new space approaches is
also a central element of esa's agenda
2025. ladies and gentlemen I'm convinced
that the Haku to our mission one is only
the beginning of many fascinating
projects and activities to come and I
wish you a successful event and a very
happy Landing thank you
thank you
[Music]
hi I have been following the M1 Mission
with great attention
I am confident that this Mission will
provide precious data and experience
which will support i-space commercial
development in the years to come
i-space has been among the first space
resources focused companies to come to
Luxembourg and we are very proud to have
been able to support the team since the
very beginning
after the successful listing of i-space
on the Tokyo Stock Exchange beginning of
April we look forward to the next
chapter of ispace success story and
particularly to the M2 Mission which
will onboard a Rover made in Luxembourg
[Music]
iron group provides a key element of the
probation system for the lender
and the assembly on integration
facilities our orbital population teams
supported i-space with the integration
on the testing of the entire vehicle in
our clean rooms in Lumber thousands as
well as in external facilities in
Germany in addition
space on iron group I've teamed up under
an either commercial partnership pilot
phase to provide Europe with an
integrated transportation system to the
Moon combining the iron 6 launcher and
the ispacelander with this M1 mission
ispace has become the first commercial
company to which lunar orbit
The Landing attempt will Mark first used
of an iron group operation system for
landing on the moon regardless of the
outcome
the i-space M1 mission is a huge
accomplishment this
is a striking example of synergistic
collaboration between what some would
call An established space company and
new space companies
i-space is a very Dynamic and Innovative
new space company
we appreciate their trust
and they are agile and deficient ways of
working with us this demonstrates iron
group's ability to provide
state-of-the-art equipment on support to
new space companies
good luck for the landing
foreign
[Music]
hello and welcome to our Global live
stream of the planned lunar Landing of
mission 1 in i-space hakto R program
the main language of this event is
English but you can watch and listen
with simultaneous Japanese translation
by accessing the stream on our hakto R
Channel
my name is Kevin zaleski and I am the MC
for today's event thank you very much
for joining us
[Applause]
many of you may have followed the launch
of mission 1 last December now after
several months of operations in space
our series one Lander is quickly
approaching one of the most exciting
moments during mission 1. in our hakto R
program the first ever private lunar
Landing
for those of you not familiar with us
ispace is a global lunar exploration
company engaging in the lunar Quest our
vision is to expand human activity into
space and to develop the future sis
lunar economy by offering reliable
payload delivery and data services
ispace has three offices its
headquarters in Japan as well as
steadily growing offices in the U.S and
Luxembourg
our first commercial lunar exploration
program consists of two missions
planned lunar landing on mission 1 and
lunar landing and surface exploration on
Mission 2. with vision one in progress
as we speak we have already started
preparations such as testing for mission
2 currently planned for 2024
furthermore I space this rapidly
progressing development for Mission 3
currently planned for 2025 which will
not only use our next Generation Series
2 Lander but will also deliver payloads
for the NASA Clips program to lunar
orbit and surface
ispace is a member of Team Draper and
proud to contribute to the Artemis
program during its upcoming mission 3.
today we are following the progress of
our mission from a venue close to the
hakto r Mission Control Center
we are here at the Neo skida kudasten
Exhibition at the national museum of
emerging science and Innovation on
odaiba Tokyo
as you can see we are surrounded by a
moon themed landscape including a
full-scale model of our series one
Lander so you can imagine that everyone
is super excited to land on the real
moon today
our series one Lander on mission 1 is
being monitored from the hakto r Mission
Control Center or MCC during its descent
towards the lunar surface
as you can see in this live feed our
team is getting ready for landing
now before we continue with our coverage
here on location let us first hear from
our MCC crew about what exactly we
expect to happen during the next
approximately 50 minutes
hi everyone we are the ispace operation
team and we are here today in the
hagoutwar MCC Mission Control Center to
execute a really special operation so we
have worked so hard to get to this point
in which we are going to perform the
landing sequence we are more than 20
Engineers getting ready preparing and
executing these Special Operations and
you are going to be able to follow from
home you are going to have a special
animation based in our data in which you
will be able to follow the whole Landing
sequence for us it's going to be a
little bit more difficult and the
analysis why
now the reason why it's a little more
difficult for us is because one all we
can do during this time is monitor the
Lander because the landing sequence is
actually autonomous so another reason
why it's going to be a little difficult
is because during the landing sequence
we are going to experience something
called an occultation now an occultation
is something that occurs when the moon
is between the Lander and our ground
station on Earth so during our Landing
sequence you can see our Landers going
to come behind the moon like so and for
about 40 minutes we're going to lose
communication with it and then only
until we pop out the other side when we
have communication again and be able to
see our Lander autonomously land on the
Moon
as we heard from Janelle earlier the
Lander is expected to have already
performed its deorbit insertion maneuver
autonomously
as you can see on our Live status
display here our Lander is now on the
moon's far side and heading for its
designated landing area
we expect to re-establish Communication
in approximately 30 minutes
now I would like to give the word to
ispace founder and CEO Takeshi hakamada
hello my name is
founder Civil Right space
in 2010 a small company with a big
vision
was born and then after 13 years and the
meeting many cargills and supporters
we have reached to the day when our
under we run on the moon
in the early days not many people
believed that we could actually run on
the moon
but we give
breathing and they worked very hard and
then as a result I'm really proud to be
here with you today
since our mission one launched in
December last year
our under and our team
have already achieved amazing things
succeeding Izumi
succeeding operation of privately funded
and then developed hardware and the
software and the payload in space for
over 100 days
now we are getting close to our
destination for mission 1.
do not rounding and surface operation
however I want to emphasize again that
our accomplishment 8 out of 10 Milestone
successes
we contribute to our development of our
next missions mission 2 and Mission 3
which already have started in parallel
I want to thank everyone for their
contributions
and ideally excited to see the outcome
of this critical movement of mission one
and I cannot wait to apply everything we
have been learned throughout our future
missions
everything we have achieved until this
point we already considered tremendous
success
thank you and let's run to the Moon
thank you
we're very excited to give you a closer
look at the status of our Lander and
what we expect to happen today but first
let us hear from ispace CTO Rio ugie for
details about our achievements during
mission 1 so far and what we hope to
achieve today
[Music]
so Eugene Sun can you tell us a little
bit about the mission one Milestone okay
yeah sure and you know as you know in
total we have a 10 success Milestone but
we have already completed eight of ten
Milestone let me explain our achievement
one by one then our first Milestone
success one is a completion of launch
preparation because you know even before
around we had to do a lot of things
including testing custom reintegration
on song that was also really great
achievement for us and after that
success to happen that is like a
separation from around to vehicle
because you are in the launch operation
the land needed to withstand really hard
mechanical condition then success 3 came
success 3 is a completion of initial
critical operation that was a really
critical movement for us then but
finally we established really stable
communication attitude and power
condition of the render then after that
in order to fly to the moon we need to
control our you know the trajectory I
mean random trajectory then you know we
carried out the fast orbital control
maneuver then we achieved the successful
then after one month in a steady flight
operation success five came and then we
kept operating a few more orbital
control maneuver then you know if when
we are ready we were ready for the first
lunar obviously session money but that
is a success six and the success 7 is a
movement to enter the lunar gravity
region then the renderer carried out
really wrong bomb to enter the gravity
region and that was also really really
in critical operation but we
successfully completed that operation
too even you know during the lunar
orbiting phase we carried out a few more
in orbital control Maneuvers and then
now we are ready for the landing
sequence and we are in success 8 then we
will move on success 9 success 9 is a
competition of our Landing sequence
running secrets to service just wonder
but most critical movement in our
mission then if we successfully land on
the moon and then established steady
communication and power status finally
we deployed our customer Rubber and then
complete success team
okay so there
do you think you could tell us a little
bit more about about some of the
critical moments that you experienced
okay definitely the success three then
successory is a completion of initial
critical operation in general of course
this is a you know a really critical
moment for all spacecraft but uh you
know the Even in our case we were
struggling with the competition of this
success Milestone because in
communication and the attitude were not
as our brand but there are in our fried
shame and showed really great
performance and then finally we achieved
this movement and then this success gave
us more confident in our in reference
capability
so you mentioned several times about
Maneuvers can you tell us a little bit
more about that okay yes the manuba
means
when we you know we carry out the
orbital control maneuver we always use
this our main proportional system then
we buy the carrying out this orbital
control manure we can control the
trajectory of the Randa then even you
know the when we enter the Runa gravity
region we also need to carry out really
really long orbital control maneuver
operation it is a more than seven
minutes plan but means you know we need
to keep activating this propulsion
system more than you know the seven
minutes then that was a really really
critical operation and then you know we
were really very nervous about that then
this is also great achievement to carry
out this type of really critical
operation as a commercial space startups
then this success seven you know the
achievement was a really great moment
for us
so there are actually quite a few
Milestones why did you choose to set 10
okay yeah because you know our mission
is not zerosome game you know the in
each steps we can learn a lot of things
we can gain our top experience knowledge
and we can also prove our fight
capability in each step then we set a 10
mile Zone and in each Milestone we have
experienced different you know the
operation and we proved different
capability then we set a 10 Milestone
and then to to show our capability and
then based on this Milestone we can
reflect our presence around into the
future mission
our lead Lander system engineer who
oversees the overall integration of our
Lander system and payloads
welcome back statsan
thank you Kevin
so our CTO usesan just told us that we
have achieved Milestone 8 already
looking at our status display
uh where do you think we are now with
our Lander
ah yes Kevin so as our city with Jason
just explained so we have completed all
the Milestones up to success 8 which
means that we are ready for the landing
sequence that means we are now moving
towards success nine uh which is lunar
Landing
so as you can see the number is now
currently on the back side of the moon
and waiting for it to establish a
communication with the ground station
and they appear from the the back side
of the moon to uh uh to finally land on
the sunny sun Side of the Moon now thank
you Mr Sun and with the planned lunar
Landing approaching quickly let us have
a look at a summary of today's expected
events
[Music]
we're going to the moon and we're just
getting started
[Music]
after 100 days of deep space Cruise the
series one Lander arrived in lunar orbit
the successful completion of this long
Voyage not only validates the series one
lunar lander design
it represents the completion of a series
of successes for ispace the verification
of our communication technology
structural design software maneuver
operations and others all while having
overcome unexpected issues and hurdles
along the way
after completing a series of orbital
control maneuvers
the Lander is scheduled to initiate its
automated Landing sequence from lunar
orbit
throughout this phase the Lander
continues to orbit the Moon while
approaching its designated landing area
other than the primary Landing location
in Atlas crater three alternative sites
can be targeted in case that any
anomalies or other unexpected events
prevent the start of the landing
sequence for the primary candidate site
in that case additional orbits are
performed to align the Lander's
trajectory with the new Target sites and
to allow for optimal use of lunar
daytime after landing
during the landing sequence the Lander
performs a series of automated actions
approximately one hour before planned
touchdown the Lander begins to deorbit
insertion phase firing its Thruster to
reduce its parallel altitude from
approximately 100 kilometers to 25
kilometers
continuing on its orbit the Lander moves
to The Far Side of the Moon losing
direct line of sight and communication
with ground station
approximately 45 minutes later the
Lander reappears from behind the moon
and begins its braking burn to slow down
its descent onboard instruments are used
to determine the distance from the lunar
surface the Lander utilizes a power
descend control algorithm developed by
Draper Laboratories using proprietary
guidance navigation and Control software
drawing from years of experience dating
back to the Apollo program
in the final moments before landing the
Lander relies on its assist thrusters to
perform a soft touchdown
[Music]
attempting a lunar Landing brings many
challenges this is truly a daring
Endeavor the impact of Landing is
mitigated by a shock absorption system
inside the landing gear after landing
the lantern performs initial checkout
activities to confirm the Integrity of
its systems simultaneously stable power
delivery to all systems is resumed and
electricity is generated via the service
mounted solar arrays a high gain antenna
will be used when attempting to
establish Communications with ground
station
next the deployment and operation of
payloads begins such as the uae's
Rasheed Rover as part of the Emirates
lunar Mission a transformable lunar
robot for the Japan Aerospace
Exploration Agency
experimental devices such as solid-state
batteries by nutera and multiple
payloads within the Canadian space
agency's LEAP program
on mission 1 surface operations are
expected to last approximately 10 days
effectively using lunar daytime for the
Lander and its payloads to perform
various tasks among others and
representing the first such transaction
of its kind
ownership of lunar regolith is planned
to be captured by the ispace series 1
Lander during landing and will be
transferred to NASA as part of the
Artemis program
as the first mission of the series one
Lander data collected during the entire
Mission duration will contribute towards
future developments
and will help to improve the performance
and reliability of ispaces Hardware
during its next missions
mission 2 is currently planned for 2024
and testing has already begun with
several customers already standing by to
have their payloads transported to the
Moon
planned for 2025 Mission 3 will be
utilized for the Fulfillment of NASA
Clips task orders as a member of Team
Draper preparations are underway and are
progressing rapidly
we're aiming to perform the world's
first lunar Landing by a commercial
Enterprise this is the beginning of our
vision to create a CIS lunar economy
i-space is in it for the long ride and
we're just getting started never quit
the lunar Quest
[Music]
now as explained during the video our
series one Lander continues to orbit the
Moon while getting closer and closer to
the surface
there is no communication link with the
Lander for a large portion of this
process but the required actions are
pre-scheduled and the lender executes
them according to our calculations
let us hear a bit more about what
exactly we expect to happen until
planned touchdown again from
tell us a bit about the expected initial
status of our Lander before landing
yeah thank you very much Kevin and
pleasure to be here to explain all the
sequences of the landing so basically we
do have six different phases as I think
the animation showed previously so all
those phases are very important to
achieve the successful Landing so as you
can see the first step what we're
calling phase one uh this is the orbit
insertion so the orbit insertion is
should burn of our main engine to the
orbit from the orbit the the circular
lunar orbit and enters into a new
trajectory for the landing
um so in this phase
um we are uh still the London is at the
very high speed about 6 000 kilometer
per hour and uh
then do
um uh less than a minute of uh a main
proportion system to fire the main
proportion system to do this this one
I see and what happens next
and the next step is the clues Landing
phase so in this phase the Lander
cruises in this new trajectory after DOI
so in this phase basically the velocity
doesn't change much but the altitude
changes drastically from 100 kilometer
to 25 kilometers
and so basically the lunar gravity is
still pulling the Lambda to decrease the
uh the altitude and up to 25 kilo and
this phase actually lasts between 40 and
50 minutes in the entire sequence so
entire sequence is about one hour and
seven minutes but this this phase is
actually the longest phase in in the
mission
and it also the very important point is
that after the phase two is completed
and before the phase the next phase
starts the lender is expected to appear
from the back side of the moon again
I see and what happens in the next phase
oh yes so next phase is phase three so
this is a breaking burn phase so
breaking burn phase is as it says we are
going to start playing with means that
we we're going to reduce the speed for
the landing so as you can see now the
velocity now
um we are changing the velocity from
6000 kilometer power to to a 100 100
kilometer hour so basically we are going
from the spacecraft speed to like a
shinkansen speed now to uh to land on
the ball so then altitude also changing
from 25 kilo to three kilo in this phase
so the Lander gets closer and closer to
the moon and keeps slowing down what
happens next
yes the next phase is phase four
so in phase four the Lander still
continues to Blake but uh still going
over about 300 kilometer per hour uh so
it's still at the synchron speed but
then it's changing the orientation to a
vertical orientation the pointing it's
you know the disasters uh straight to
down to the to the lunar surface so as
you can see at the end of this phase the
London is going to be only uh one
kilometer above the lunar surface
and next it gets really interesting
doesn't it
yes this is uh very exciting and those
those phase all of the phases are most
important but
those number five and number six uh I I
can say most important phases in the
entire sequence
thank you and then the moment everyone
is waiting for the Final Phase
uh yes so the Final Phase is uh phase
six so this is terminal Landing so here
the velocity is now uh yes to 70
kilometer per hour so now it's changing
from shingles and speed to now to the
bicycle lighting speed and eventually uh
at the end
um
it's going to uh
walking uh kind of pace so then altitude
is changing from 20 meter to zero so
this is a very last moment of the
landing and we are going to shut off uh
the main engine and Leela is only on the
assistant to adjust the attitude and uh
for the final moments and hopefully for
the soft Landing
we are all rooting for our Lander
getting closer and closer to the lunar
surface and now let's have a look maybe
at our status screen again
um that's done where does this put us in
the landing approach right now
uh yes so we I think the uh The Phase
One have uh been already completed
expected to have already completed by
now so we are now in the phase two which
is a close phase so the London should be
now um descending from the altitude of
100 kilo towards uh to the 25 kilos so
we are in the middle of that process
right now thank you
isan are you slowly getting a little bit
nervous
not at all I'm just watching a
successful riding
thank you very much and now I would also
like to welcome distinguished guests on
our stage today the first is professor
yuichitsuda professor tsuda not only
teaches at Tokyo University but is also
in charge of the Hayabusa 2 program at
the Japan Aerospace Exploration Agency
see the sound welcome
yeah thank you and thank you for letting
me be here and I'm really excited
to witness this great events and
congratulations to hakamarasana icepace
team for the success so far
and I was leading the mission called
Hayabusa 2. that is an asteroid sample
return mission that was successfully
completed three years ago
so what I did there was uh to fly the
spacecraft to an Ever unexplored acid
ryugu
and landed there twice
and collected samples and returned them
back to the Earth
so
so isn't it cool
so what you're going to do is to send a
spacecraft to a Celestial body that has
20 000 Times Higher gravity than that of
ryugu
only with the power of the private
sector
so what a challenge
so if this is not a challenge
nothing can be challenged called
challenge
so
I think the history can be made only by
those who challenges and
challenges
would not be possible without taking a
risk
and the risk
can be taken only by those who dreams
so I space themes you are all excellent
dreamers
so I hope all your success and more
importantly I'm an engineer so from the
engineering point of view
get as much data as possible
throughout this learning process
and recall all the experience throughout
this mission
for for for for the uh most sustainable
lunar activity that you are going to do
and for to expand this lunar exploration
activity to remote Global one so
godspeed I space godspeed hard thank you
thank you very much thank you
thank you very much Professor Tuda and
we wish you all the best with your
future endeavors please enjoy the show
next I am happy to welcome Airbus
Ventures manager partner Thomas here on
stage with us Airbus Ventures has been
one of our first International
shareholders and they possess a strong
insight into the global space industry
thank you and first congratulations
akamarasan the entire icepace team on
this historic moment thank you very much
and thank you for bringing all of us
closer to the moon and to the Moon right
so Airbus Ventures Louis my friend and
the entire team we cannot be more proud
today uh to be here joining in this
extraordinary uh milestone for the space
economy maybe a word about the moon uh
we uh adventures and you at i-space
Value the moon as a vital system
component
in harnessing natural resources
in order to deliver
clean energy
rare metal but also a biosphere friendly
manufactured product to Earth but the
moon's developments is also critical
for alleviating the compounding stresses
that we've seen on Earth climate and
Earth biodiversity this is also a
tremendous opportunity a business an
economic opportunity that now we see
ispace uniquely positioned to Pioneer so
this world is full of planetary system
challenges
i-space now with the talent the global
mindsets but also this sustained vision
and the thorough execution and the
global team building along these years
of development is a key actor to address
those planetary challenges so our
message to the team is to keep going the
Moon is away and please again
congratulations for this historic moment
thank you thank you akabanasan thank you
thank you very much
thank you Mr Delaware and we are very
excited for the future may bring forth
private space now I'm very excited to
welcome another ispace crew member here
at our venue Scott Moon our lead
assembly testing and integration manager
who helped not only build the series one
Lander for mission one but who is
already working on our mission to Lander
hello Scott and please take a seat and
tell us a bit more about how the mission
one Lander came into existence sure
Kevin so I had the Good Fortune to join
ispace in November 2020
and in April of 2021 the i-space team
was deployed to Germany to begin
building the M1 Lander we spent the next
year in Germany building the Lander in
uh in those facilities
and after one year we moved to Munich to
start our test campaign on that lunar
lander when we were in Munich we ran
tests that allowed us to simulate the
environment that we would see in deep
space we ran tests to simulate the
environment we would see during the
SpaceX Falcon 9 launch and we ran tests
of all of the systems that we needed to
use while we were in orbit while we were
descending and while we were in
operation on the moon
once we finished all those tests we
packed up our operations in Germany and
we flew on a specialized cargo transport
over the Atlantic to arrive at Kennedy
Space Center in Cape Canaveral
the AIT team personally escorted the
Lander over and once we landed in
Florida we spent two months with our
launch preparations which included
fueling the Lander and doing a final
systems checkout
after those two months we said goodbye
to our lunar lander we put it inside the
Fairing and it was integrated into the
launch vehicle to be launched in
December of 2022. that's basically the
M1 story in a nutshell
thank you Scott you're welcome and again
thank you for your hard work
now of course our series one Lander is
not going to the Moon empty-handed it is
carrying several payloads expected to
start operations on the lunar surface
after landing let us hear about our
payload customers on M1 from ispace
Chief Revenue officer atsushi psyche
[Applause]
tell us who is going to the Moon with us
okay thank you Kevin
uh on mission one uh we are carrying a
number of government and Commercial
payloads our payload service does not
only consist of bringing something to
the moon but also I space closely
communicate and coordinate with its uh
customers to integrate each payload into
the Lander and its system
secondly the payloads are tested before
the launch to verify their ability to
survive the long journey to the Moon
and I space further uh
uh offer power delivery and
Communication Service to payloads that
require it during transit to the Moon as
well as after successful Landing
throughout the mission our series one
Lander also offer protection from the
harsh environment of space by providing
thermal control and other services
our payloads on mission 1 vary in size
mass and objectives some of them are
mobile and we plan to deploy them from
our Lander after touchdown such as the
mbrc Russian Rover and the Jackson
transformable lunar robot
after deployment these Rovers will begin
their mission objectives on the lunar
surface while sending and receiving data
and commands via our mission control
center in Tokyo
other payloads will stay integrated into
the Lander we carry experimental
solid-state battery for nitera which
perform verification tests of this new
Battery Technology under extreme
environment in space and the lunar
surface
further we carry several payloads within
the Canadian lead program an AI powered
flight computer by mcss as well as a
camera system featuring wide-angle
cameras by canadensis
further our partnership program involves
corporations from various Industries and
Fields in the exciting new challenge
towards the Moon we cooperate with
companies as you can see on the screen
here
we believe that the transport and
operation of these payloads provides an
exceptional value to our customers not
only in terms of space and lunar
exploration but also in the development
of new technologies that could benefit
Human Society on Earth in the future
thank you Kevin thank you sike San and
we are all super excited to bring more
and more companies to the Moon
now for a bit of background on how I'll
Lander and its payloads are deployed and
operated after landing let's hear it
from our MCC crew again
thank you
[Applause]
as soon as our spacecraft detects
contact with the lunar surface it will
go to TDM which is touchdown mode it
will cut off the engines and make sure
that we're stable on the lunar Surface
after that we'll perform many checkouts
to make sure every system and our
customers are still working as expected
one of the first things that we will do
is deploy our hiking antenna when we're
on the surface so our highgen antenna
will allow us to download all of the
data and pictures and photos that we've
taken throughout our mission
the lunar environment is completely
different than the environment we've
been facing up until this point
most people probably think the Moon is
this cold desolate place but it can get
very hot in the sunlight up to 120
degrees C
so the first thing we do again is a full
checkout of our system
and once we have our High Gain antenna
which allows us to send much more data
back to Earth than we could in Cruise
then we're ready to deploy our customer
Rovers the bigger one is the mbrsc Rover
so it has been flying up here once it's
time to deploy the arm folds down with
the Rover on it and then we release the
Rover and it can drive off to go do some
great science
foreign
and all the best during those first
moments of surface operations
now we are happy to have a quick message
from a very special guest
a former jaxa astronaut who flew on the
space shuttle to the International Space
Station will very soon be connecting
remotely with us
Amazon hello can you hear us
hello Kevin yes I can hear very well and
congratulations for your achievement so
far
yes I am so thrilled and honored to be
with you for the upcoming historic
moment first ever private lunar Landing
first of all I'm so proud of the entire
i-space team including families
for the remarkable achievement to get
this point as an astronaut I cannot
overstate the importance of this Mission
which expands our Frontier for all
humankind
my dream is to open a school on the moon
someday so that various students from
various countries and regions can learn
together on the moon watching the Earth
from a distance
the moon has a huge Potentials in many
ways so it is important M1 and following
missions will secure High frequent
transportation to the Moon which will
secure human presence on the moon and
allows us to have a big dream
also as a member of the temporary member
of National Space policy Committee of
Japan M1 means a lot to governments too
ispace is the first company to be
covered by space resources act in Japan
and awarded a contract with NASA for
lunar resources
and M1 contains uae's learner robber and
Canadian Japanese parents and so on
uh when I visit i-space Mission Control
Center in Tokyo a couple months ago I
had a privilege to write a message on
the wall and I wrote
fly our dreams to the moon so thank you
very much for flying our dreams to the
Moon
so proud of your never give up Spirits
all the best and God's spirit
thank you so much Yama zaksan and it's
always a great pleasure to have you with
us
now let us have another quick look at
our status screen
uh looking at the status screen I hope
we have it now here soon yes what phase
would you put us on now more or less
yes I think I believe uh the lender is
still in the phase two that doesn't face
so as I said this this phase takes about
40 to 50 minutes so I hope that in the
uh I think about in the 10 10 minutes or
so I hope that the next uh the black and
burn starts but at the moment I I
believe that Orlando still is in the
cruise phase uh flying with a speed of 6
000 kilometer per hour and but altitude
now you can see the altitude altitude is
now uh getting now closer to 25 uh a
kilo from the surface
we soon hope to regain contact with our
lender are you looking forward to
meeting him again yes I really looking
forward to reconnect our render and then
start the next phase of the landing
thank you and while we wait let's see
where exactly our lender is planning to
set down on the moon
[Music]
we are collaborating with a group of
international experts to have finding
suitable Landing sites on the moon this
can allow the missions to have 12 days
of sunlight on the lunar surface let's
start with where are these four
candidate Landing sites
well we're having four Landing sites one
prime lending site which is the most
exciting one we find which is atlas
greater and we have three backup Landing
sites one is not too far from the prime
lending side which is
London in the Western Hemisphere where
we have
foreign
all of our Landing sites are in the
Northern Hemisphere and well are very
exciting for the scientific potential
and are well suitable to actors
backup Landing site in case Landing does
not work of any of the others
we selected our site using both
scientific and Technical criterias so
for instance we want to go to a place
relatively flat avoided of bulldozers
but we also want to maximize the science
outputs with having some geological
diversity
and in order to proceed we collected
data from space mission currently
orbiting the Moon that we processed we
tried to translate to criterias into
calculation steps and then we came up
with a list of possible sites that we
scored and we ranked
I think from the beginning The Landing
site selection work group started with
having safety in mind the safety of
landing and also safety of Russia driver
traversing the moon Russia dropper is
designed to to overcome obstacles of up
to 10 centimeters of height and also to
drive over the slopes of Maximum 20
degrees
when we reach there definitely we have a
lot of ideas to do a lot of science
experiments we are going to study the
regulator on the landing side and also
we are going to study the thermal
characteristics and also we have a nice
and exciting ideas on experimenting with
different materials interacting with the
regulator on the landing side
so my role was to I guess further
optimize our Landing site selection make
sure that there was alignment with both
our lancetine here in ispace as well as
our other customer payloads as well as
to establish our own science objectives
to help with the continuous Improvement
of ispace Lander and Rover exploration
missions into the future each of the
four selected Landing sites are
incredibly unique and will offer
fantastic scientific value and they're
just really exciting opportunities
for like to land on any of the given
Landing sites we have to make sure
they're special of this passing over it
but then as the moon rotates over in its
own access uh we only have one given
opportunity every lunar month right so
every 28 days so in order to minimize
the time that passes between any of the
Prime and the uh any of the learning
opportunities in case there's any
deviation from from the nominal then we
selected these three learning sets that
will be accessible within just a few
days
and a big thank you to our colleagues at
mbrc crpg ispace Europe and everyone
else who contributed to this very
critical part of mission one
now while we wait for the Lander to
reappear From The Far Side of the Moon
and reconnect with our ground station
let us hear about what we can look
forward to over the next couple of years
I welcome ispace director and chief
finance officer jumpe nozaki
okay thank you Kevin so I'll wait for
Mission One landing let's talk about the
future so we have mission two next year
and Mission 3 in 2025 and let me explain
mission 2 will use a series one render a
same as well right now in the space but
we'll also bring a micro robot which
currently our Luxembourg team is
developing and also for Mission 3 right
now our next Generation Lander sees two
Lander is manufactured in the U.S
Colorado Denver and uh this uh will
bring two satellites to the lunar orbit
and also they will land on the far side
of the moon so this is very fantastic
Mission uh in going forward in 2025 and
also Mission 3 we are going to bring
NASA payroll under a program called
Eclipse commercial lunar payroll service
so we will contribute to a NASA our team
is program too
so next page I like to to stress most
important thing about a sustainable
business model so we are not a company
doing just one single Mission but rather
we are doing three Missions at the same
time all together this is very important
because uh while we are doing mission
one we can feedback what we learned from
Amazon one and the data what we acquired
from mission one two mission two and
mission three lapidry and this is really
important to improve our maturity of
technology and also maturity of a
business model
and also uh for startup companies the
financing is very important but uh we
are very proud and we are very uh
fortunate that we could raise more than
300 million US dollar of money so far to
support not only one single Mission but
all three missions together so this is
an important point to create a
sustainable business as I space so we
are now closer to the landing and I
believe I strongly believe we cannot
have a good achievement but however if
any whatever the outcome is our country
a company will go and continue and also
uh I promise uh never a question in a
quest so thank you very much Kevin thank
you nozaksan
and we are all very excited to see the
progress on our follow-up missions now I
would like to welcome Scott moon on the
stage once again
Scott join us once more please thanks
Kevin
thank you Scott and we just heard that
preparation mission 2 are already in
full swing tell us a little bit more
about the ongoing assembly integration
and testing activities sure so during
the M1 integration testing that I
described earlier we gained a lot of
valuable information about how the Land
Air responds and how it fits together
and our design teams have already
Incorporated all that information into
the design of the M2 Lander making some
small improvements to improve the
performance
also the last hundred days in space
flight have given us very valuable
information about how we perform in
space and this information has also
already been incorporated into our
updated design so we spent the last four
months with our teams building a
development model of the M2 Lander and
the testing on this has been completed
two weeks ago
this information tells us how the new
design will be performing we're also
incorporating this inform information
into our new design and I'm really happy
to announce that as of last week we
started building M2 flight model Lander
the first pieces have already been
assembled and we are on our way to the
M2 launch
thank you Scott
you're welcome
and it's really amazing that even while
mission one is still ongoing we are
already working on our next mission so
good luck to you and your team
so
um
I have a good uh
live update for all of you we received
word that the Lander has reappeared from
the back side of the moon
and it's on its final orbit
only minutes away from the planned
Landing
so-san
seems like it's really happening yeah I
feel well it's really happening yes very
very excited to see very final phase of
the landing soon
yes so uh we can really just hope and
send our good energies towards the
Lander so we starts on looking at the
display what is the status
so it looks like we I think that the
display still the simulation modes but I
think it seems that if everything is
going as expected I think we have we
should have entered now the black
inbound phase so it should be
um maybe the altitude is about 25 kilo
and if everything is okay then I think
Blake blinking burn is continuing to
slow down the speed from six cells from
about a hundred uh thousand kilometer
per hour to a hundred sorry a few
hundred kilometer per hour thank you Mr
Sun and actually for everyone here we
were able to download several images and
videos from our lender over the last few
days again these are not real-time
images but they were taken from lunar
orbit around 100 kilometer
altitude so let's have a look at these
images
so this first image
look at it it's just beautiful yeah
beautiful and then very incredible
pictures taken from our under
This truly amazing how a
privately funded spacecraft can capture
the moon and the earth like this and
send the image back now
looking at this I think this image also
contains some scientific very very
interesting specialty can you explain it
a bit more oh yes yeah so this is uh the
picture of the uh the Earth's lies on
the moon but most interestingly you know
as you can see if you can take a very
closer look at the RS so we see actually
the shadow of the Moon uh on on the
earth so you see that the black spot
there the closer close to the Australia
so this is actually the shadow of the
moon so we we took this picture uh
during the solar eclipse so it's really
interesting to see this kind of uh the
phenomena not from the Earth but from
the lunar orbit so this is really
interesting and very exciting picture
thank you Mr Sun and I believe we also
have a video that I would like to share
with you
wow
[Applause]
doesn't this look amazing well this is
real video yes not CZ no
it's amazing
it's really hard to believe
but it looks amazing
we see something in the lower part of
the video what is this
yes I think this is a part of our London
so this is the part that we call mli a
multi-layer installation
mli and we see the personal logo at the
on the light hand side so it's really
great it's really amazing to see this
you know Shadow and the blight part and
the shadow part of the of the of the
Melissa because there's no atmosphere on
the moon so it's we can clearly see the
the surface and this is really amazing
video I'm I'm really amazed
thank you
and I believe we have one more image
yet again a video
[Applause]
well another amazing well video I cannot
tell any world
beautiful
it really transcends words and it is
just amazing so now I would like to ask
hakamadasan and to join our crew on your
seats and for the last few minutes we
are almost five minutes before Plant
Landing I would like to ask you to
continue viewing the event and let's all
root for our Lander while we wait for
the planned Landing
thank you
and now looking at the status screen the
Lander is still moving
over 2 000 kilometers per hour
please let me point out here that we
might lose communication with our Lander
during descent
this is to be expected
and we will reconnect as quickly as
possible
also if you see any sudden changes in
the simulation this might also be caused
by our system of how we simulate it
even if the Lander appears to be on the
surface or anywhere else please wait for
our final confirmation from our MCC
as soon as we receive final word we will
share it with you
and you see our MCC crew
getting ready for the moment
anxiously awaiting
getting their stations ready
here in Tokyo
in our U.S office and our Luxembourg
office
everyone
is awaiting
now we are around three minutes before
landing
you can see the tension in everyone's
faces
but these are professionals and we trust
them
now we see
the speed of our Lander in the upper
right corner around 700 kilometers per
hour under seven kilometers above the
surface
we are getting closer and closer
the Lander continues to fire its
propulsion system and we are now around
L minus two minutes
close to 500 kilometers per hour under
six kilometers above surface
we are only moments away from the
planned touchdown on the learning
surface
everyone who worked on this mission is
anxiously anticipating how it will turn
out please note again communication with
our Lander may be interrupted during the
send and it might therefore take a
little bit of time for our grand crew to
confirm the status of our Lander we will
share the latest situation with you as
soon as possible
even if you see the lunar landed the
land Lander
landed on the surface
we will update you
as soon as possible now only 200
kilometers per hour under three
kilo kilometers above the surface only
one minute to go
190 180 kilometers per hour
under two kilometers
the lunar lander keeps breaking
now in vertical orientation
only one kilometer above the surface
remaining
we're getting closer and closer
about 120 kilometers per hour 700 meters
we will soon have reached the planned
Landing time
at which point
I might ask you to wait for a few
moments for us to confirm the status
60 kilometers per hour
20 meters Final Approach
10 meters
and our simulation might have lost its
connection with the MCC no
reason to for concern yet we are still
seeing the animation going three
kilometers per hour
only meters above the surface now
and now we are at the moment of planned
Landing time again everyone please give
us a few moments to confirm
we hope to maybe receive a message from
our MCC soon
if that is not the case then we will
need a few moments to continue
investigations and we'll update you as
soon as we have new information
our MCC crew
standing by
waiting to confirm
everyone is laser focused right now
you can really feel the tension
please allow us a little bit more time
to confirm the status of our Lander
our MCC ground team keeps working
confirms whether or not we can receive
Telemetry from our Lander
so they are continuing to investigate
this process may still take a little bit
of time
we see all different kinds of
Expressions here it's really difficult
to tell from our seats
and it is so difficult feeling powerless
now but all we can do is Cheer them up
and trust them
please give us a few more moments
we are still in the process of
confirmation
the team keeps on working tirelessly
attempting to re-establish communication
with our Lander after the planned
Landing time has passed
thank you
thank you everyone for your patience I
know everyone wants to know the status
of our Lander
and I assure you
our crew is working on it as we speak
so while we continue to confirm
we will be with you again in a few
moments thank you very much for your
patience and we will
give you updates as soon as we have them
thank you for your patience and we'll be
right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you for your patience as of now
our MCC crew is still continuing to
investigate the Landers status so we ask
you to bear with us a little bit longer
and we will be right back thank you for
your patience
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
at this moment we haven't now able to
confirm successful landing on the lunar
surface
our engineers at MCC is
continue to investigate the current
status of the render
currently we have not confirmed the
communication from durander
we already confirmed that we have
established the communication until very
end of the rounding
however
now we lost the communication
so we have to assume that
we our
it may uh
we could not complete the landing on the
lunar surface
our Engineers will continue to
investigate the situation and then we
will update you the further information
once we finish the uh investigation
at this moment what I can tell is we are
very proud of the facts that we have
already achieved many things during this
mission one
as I said we have been secured the
communication at the very end of The
Landing that means we acquired actual
flight data during the landing phase
that is great achievement for the future
missions mission 2 and Mission 3
to the end
that is important to feedback what we
learned from this mission 1 to Mission 2
and the mission 3. that's why we built
our sustainable business model
to continue our effort for the future
missions
I'd like to thank you
all the employees
who have who have been contributed to
this Mission since the beginning of this
company
and then to the present
and then also
our families
who continues to support us
and this our shareholders
hacked our partners
and our customers
and the surprise
and everyone
who believe in eye space vision
we will keep going
never quit do not Quest
they may allow to
speak in Japanese to the Japanese
audience next
okoro
um
foreign
[Applause]
and thank you to everyone who joined us
for our coverage today please don't
forget to follow ispace on and hakto r
on social media for future updates you
can find us on Twitter Facebook LinkedIn
and YouTube also if you are in Tokyo you
can see a life-size model of our series
one Lander at the Neo skidakudasten
Exhibition at the national museum of
emerging science and Innovation here on
odaiba and don't forget never quit the
lunar Quest
foreign